but my friends we cannot have security
at home without security abroad that's
why our tough foreign and defense
secretaries are updating the integrated
review to make sure we can face down
these threats
it's why we're increasing defense
spending to three percent of GDP by the
end of the decade
this will ensure that our armed forces
are ready to tackle new and emerging
threats
we're working with our friends and
allies to support Ukraine in the face of
Putin's brutal War the brave Ukrainian
people
the brave Ukrainian people aren't just
fighting for their security but for all
our security this is a fight for freedom
and democracy around the world
Putin's illegal annexation of Ukrainian
territory is just the latest act in his
campaign to subvert democracy and
violate international law
we should not give in to those who want
to deal which trades away Ukrainian land
they are proposing to pay in Ukrainian
lives for the illusion of peace
we will stand with our Ukrainian friends
however long it takes Ukraine can win
Ukraine must win and Ukraine will win
thank you